how could I say something that I want to
say now back then you know what I mean
you can't like I'd have to say it now
and I'll never get a chance to that's
tragic is there a specific scenario
you're thinking of yeah my brother my
parents lied to us our entire lives and
uh my parents bullied my brother into
committing
suicide and I'll never get to tell them
I'm sorry but I didn't know that they
were lying to me
and they were using me to argue with him
you
know
up I wish I would have told my brother I
loved him and that he had a community
that cared about him Beyond his drug
problem before he died of a fent all
overd I wish that I had told my brother
that I forgive him um my brother caused
a lot of bad things that were associated
with his substance use disorder and then
he died of a fenel overdose
and I think in my heart I know that he
knows that I love him but I wish that I
had told him that I forgive
him um I wish I would have told my
brother that it's not our fault that
he's so angry and it's not our
fault I wish I would have told my
brother to love his two children and not
hate them or push them away something I
wish I said but never
did H like when I be going around around
town you know I just be chilling here
and there I'll be seeing a beautiful
woman I'll be so scared to talk to her
because like I don't know how to explain
myself you know and try to get to know
the girl what makes me nervous cuz she
was just so beautiful and I just can't
talk to it's hard for me to talk to cute
cute women you know I get nervous they
made me smile I can't I can't think
right that's really why is this so is
this in general or is this like one
specific person you're thinking of shoot
it's one specific person if you had the
chance to talk to her what would you
have said I would have asked her how was
her life going you know how was she
doing stuff like
that I would have told
my high school computer science teacher
who was like really old
um that she's cool and that I'm sorry
for disrupting
class why do you think that came to mind
like why I don't know I just thought of
her and I've never thought of her but
she was probably like one of the nicest
teachers I had and that was probably one
of the coolest classes that I got to
take
so I wish I said you to a bunch of
people um it's something I've never said
to anybody and there's people in my life
that have been in my life that
definitely deserved a you so I wish I
would have said that to them what
stopped you from saying
it being the cool girl the chill girl
being too nice and um
yeah basically that I just I never was I
never express anger I let people just
stay in my
life I wish I would have said sorry more
often it's okay if you're not okay when
did you stop loving
me I wish I said I love you one last
time wish I told my son I loved him more
before he passed away I love you I love
you I'm sorry and I love you I love you
Dad
yeah yeah I mean he left when I was
younger but you know I gained peace with
myself on that I forgive him and I love
them so yeah I wish that on December 3rd
I'm
1999 that I had told my mom good night
and that I loved her
because the next morning she um went
into a coma and didn't wake up and I've
always wished I had said that I love
you I've met several people in my life
that I really did love okay but I just
wasn't brave enough or mature enough to
just go ahead and take the risk of
saying it you know lots of times I don't
think we really communicate how much
somebody means to us you know we're just
a little scared you know nearly every
every body is wearing a facade to some
are just wearing it to a greater degree
in other words really showing people
what you really really are and how you
are vulnerable being vulnerable is is
what we're fearful of I
believe so how about now in your life do
you tell people you love them exactly
for sure and I tell them when I don't
like them I will tell you the truth now
for what I think is the truth if the
truth is it as I perceive
it I'm feeling pretty sad right now as
lost my mom on
Friday and uh I came down to the beach
so that I would be close to
her you're the best mom ever that's what
I would have
said I think we were meant to meet today
huh right I think so um I wish I had
said to my best friend that um I
actually liked
her but she
left I don't know it was I was just
nervous to her um I don't know she was
really pretty um she made me feel
welcomed and I didn't feel um nervous
around her uncomfortable I just felt
nice with her uh the week before my dad
died I was playing the piano at home and
he came in and told me how proud he was
of me and I was being silly and I made
like a kind of silly joke about like ew
gross and I always wish I just said
Thank you and we've had a nice moment
something that I wish I could have said
was to one of my friends when I was a
teenager he uh died in a car crash our
senior year of high school and I it's
kind of funny but like I owed him $20 so
yeah I just wish I could see my friend
tell hey man here's 20 let me get you a
cup of coffee or something like that but
yeah I I wish I could just tell my
friend goodbye something that I recently
wished that I had said but hadn't yet
was I have this group of friends that I
really like them all and I've known them
for a year now and it took me literally
an entire year to like ask them to hang
out individually I think I just thought
it'd be awkward like it'd be a weird
thing to ask and then I was like oh I
shouldn't do it it's easy for me to just
not do things I don't know especially if
I feel shy or something like that I just
realized like I want to be closer to
these people so I have to just make the
effort and I finally did yesterday so I
feel really good about that and you're
hanging out with them today
yeah I wish instead of saying I do I
wish I would have said I don't on my
first marriage you're married again but
on your first marriage you wish you had
said that oh um not married at the
current moment probably never will wrong
hand oh first time she was so young I
was very young and
foolish and didn't really know who I was
marrying or what I was getting into and
he was a
bum yeah and the second one oh and the
second husband yeah and they were both
named Phillip I should have learned from
the first
Phillip biggest thing I've learned
from
Marriage um to not do it again but I
suppose it it works for some people um
yeah I think when children are involved
when children are involved yeah well it
all depends on who the father is though
yeah but what I at this ripe old age I
don't think I would marry again I don't
see any
um any point to it we're old enough
where marriage was expected at a certain
age right and this generation luckily
aren't expected to necessarily get
married yeah when we young I mean to be
uh oh my God to be pregnant and
unmarried was a shameful yeah ruined
your life and your children's life do
you have the same Outlook as your friend
here my sister your sister oh sisters
you just ask for you're only
interviewing one person yeah I've been
married twice MH second husband second
husband and it's working yeah okay yeah
I personally don't think you should be
allowed to be married before 35 you
don't know what you're doing God you
don't you can't really decide you have a
difficult time picking out clothing
little on a husband right when I
first was going to get married my first
marriage I remember probably not as old
as I thought she was but an older woman
elderly woman she was probably 40 or
something telling me and she said well
just think of it this way it's like
finding your favorite meal and then
eating it for the next 60
years get tired of it yeah right any
ending thoughts for your
segment I would say if it isn't working
out if the effort outweighs the pleasure
it's time to move on you know it's like
a bad date you don't keep going on the
same Bad Day right well yeah don't marry
anyone named Phillip I I did it
twice what do you think of marriage um
that's a good
question come on let's turn the camera
around I'll answer but uh let me see
what are my thoughts on marriage or what
are the benefits of
marriage I
um or can you see any benefits of
marriage I think it's
beautiful I do believe that like I don't
know I'm I'm like a sucker for love I do
believe that like if so was I you're
young yeah um I do I do believe in
finding someone and
like and the whole like the the thing
you said about like finding your
favorite meal and eating it every day
I'm personally the type of person where
I could eat my favorite meal every day
so like I guess it just depends on you I
could see myself falling in love with
someone and like never getting bored of
them but I also get your perspective too
maybe I'm just naive you know no a
romantic and that's a wonderful thing to
be it's just great
yeah hi everyone thank you for watching
I'll be posting bonus footage from this
episode on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
if you want to see it you can sign up
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups on the
people you see in this episode that'll
be on my patreon as well thank you guys
for watching I love you all and I'll see
you next
time